TODD KERPELMAN: We all ready?
Hey, look at that.
We're ready to go.
Hi, everybody.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh, wow.
Let's do that again.
Hi, everybody.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
Wow, I did not think this crowd
would have any energy at 3:00
on a Friday afternoon,
when everyone's tired
or hungover or both.
But this is great.
So, hi.
I am Todd Kerpelman.
Thank you for attending
the Developing with Google
on iOS presentation.
I'll be honest, I was worried
giving this talk on iOS
at Google I/O at 3 o'clock
on a Friday afternoon.
There was going
to be nobody here.
But like, there's
hundreds of you out here.
This is a big crowd.
You're all here to
see this, right?
OK.
Man, I wish I'd
known there was going
to be so many people, because
there's a lot of profanity
in this thing.
I'm going to edit as we go.
So anyhoo, often
in conversations,
when I tell people that I
am focused on iOS developer
products from Google,
the reaction I often get
is something along the
lines of, like, what?
Google doesn't do
anything on iOS, do they?
You must spend your
entire day eating snacks.
But the truth of the
matter is, actually, yes, I
do mostly snacks.
But also, no.
Here's the thing
we want to know.
Despite all of the
Android M announcements
and all the Android
Wear announcements
and all the Apple versus
Google stories you're probably
going to see in
the blogosphere, we
care deeply about
iOS developers.
We care about building
products and services
that you are all going to use.
And the fact of
the matter is, we
live in a cross-platform world.
And we can't provide
you with services
that you're going to find
great unless you can use them
everywhere you're
building your app.
And so, to that end,
we have a number
of Google services
available for iOS developers
to help you develop your
app, engage with more users,
and of course, earn
a little money.
Now we've been making
these libraries
more powerful over
the last few years.
But more recently, we've
also taken a few steps
to streamline the
developer experience
so that it is simpler
for you to add these
into your iOS project.
Combine that together and you
get something that-- ah, jeez.
That's a little more
disturbing than I
thought it was going to be.
Shoo.
Go on.
Get out.
Point being, we want
to make the power
of adding Google
to your application
simpler for all you
developers out there.
And the first big step we're
taking towards that goal
is supporting CocoaPods.
All right, applause.
Where were you guys
during the keynote?
We needed you then.
So a show of hands-- who
here has heard of CocoaPods.
That's like nearly all of you.
That's because it is awesome.
But for the benefit of those
of us joining live stream
on YouTube-- hi, YouTube--
I'm going to just tell you
why CocoaPods is awesome.
It takes care of a lot
of the steps required
for adding third-party
libraries to any iOS project.
So it does things like
grabbing ZIP files
from around the web or your
favorite GitHub repository,
extracting the files you need,
adding them to your Xcode
project-- you can activate
whatever iOS frameworks are
needed for this library to
work and add any [INAUDIBLE]
compiler flags that you might
need, and blah, blah, blah.
And of course, if any
of these libraries
depend on any other
libraries out there,
CocoaPods will go out,
find those other libraries,
repeat the entire process
until you have everything you
need for your library to work.
All these steps are taken
care of with one simple pod
install command.
Look at that.
And of course, if you
ever want to update
any of these
libraries, CocoaPods
will also go out
onto the internet,
see if anything's
changed, and if so,
reinstall it again and update it
for you with a very simple pod
update command,
assuming, of course,
that the pod specs
are up to date.
And that's something
we'll get to in a moment.
So we've talked to our
partners and most of them
have basically told us,
yeah, this is pretty much
what we do anyway.
And so we decided,
you know what?
Let's just make CocoaPods our
primary channel for releasing
Google services on iOS.
And what does that mean?
Well, for starters,
it means adding this
to our documentation.
So, hooray.
We have documentation
that reflects
how you work in the real
world, which is great.
It also means that we are going
to be owning and publishing
these pod spec files
ourselves instead of relying
on our loyal fans
on the internet
to do that for us, which we
totally appreciate, by the way.
Thank you very much, all of
you loyal fans on the internet.
We totally dig your
hipster mustache.
But you know what?
This is really work
that we should be doing,
so we're going to
take care of that.
This also means,
incidentally, that this is now
going to be part of
our build process.
So any time we create a new
build of one of our libraries,
our build tools
will automatically,
behind the scenes, create
a brand new, up-to-date pod
spec file so that it is fresh
and up-to-date and ready
to publish as soon as
the library is, which
means that you won't have
to sit around saying, hey,
this new library's
been out for weeks.
Who's going to update
the pod spec file?
Who's in charge of this thing?
Who do I need to bother?
All of this, our new pod spec
file should be ready to go
and published to the world
as soon as our library is,
which is great.
I do regret to
inform you, however,
that our actual build
process for iOS libraries
does not involve any giant
robot welding arms-- yet.
Working on it.
We're also adding
support for pod try.
How many of you out there
know what pod try is?
Yeah, fewer of you.
Pod try, it's a
lesser-known command
that is now part of CocoaPods.
And basically, the
way it works is,
let's say you're interested
in checking out some library,
but you're not ready
to commit to adding it
to your actual Xcode project
that you're working on.
The way pod try works is I say,
hey, let's pod try a library.
CocoaPods will go out, it will
find that repository out there
on the internet,
and it will scan it
for anything resembling
an Xcode, an XE Workspace,
or a project file, preferably
in a directory named something
like Demo, for example.
If it finds it, it will
download everything
onto a temporary directory
on your hard drive for you
and run it with an Xcode.
So you can fiddle
around with the code,
make changes, see how the
library interacts with you,
basically try out your example
really easily without having
to do any other work or add it
to your official Xcode project.
So to make this work, we
have started including
all of our samples in
the very same libraries
that we're supporting
so that, if you
ask to pod try any of
Google's libraries,
this should just work.
So you should give
pod try a try.
Another nice benefit of
using CocoaPods, by the way.
This should reduce
a little space.
In the past, if we had
Library A and Library B,
then they'd both require another
library to work, like, say,
a logging library.
Typically, we just bundle
everything together
and do some namespace hacking
to avoid dual include errors.
But it tended to get these
things a little bloated.
But now that we're
using CocoaPods,
we can say, hey, you know what?
Both of these
libraries, they're just
going to list this other
library as a dependency
so that no matter how many
of these others you add,
this logging library
will only be added once
to your project, which is nice.
Right now, this official
CocoaPod process
has been incorporated by
a number of our libraries.
And we're working with
many of our others
to insure this number grows
in the future, very soon.
The other part of
the process that we
want to make easier for you
is configuring everything
when you're first
getting started.
There is a lot of power
behind some of these features
we are building, particularly
when you start delving
into some of the finer
details around something
like Google Analytics.
But that's also a
lot of detail you
don't necessarily need when
you're just getting started.
Ideally, you want to
spend the first couple
minutes of your
project saying, hey,
I would like my app
to use all the things,
please give them to me.
And so that's what
our new configuration
flow is going to focus on.
Basically, we're going to
give you all the basics
and provide you with
lots of sensible defaults
so that you have what you need
to start building quickly.
This is probably
something that is better
demonstrated in
a video, so we're
going to roll the clip here.
Here I'm going to be
creating an iOS project.
I'm going to be adding a
bunch of services to it.
I'm going to add Sign-In and
Analytics and AdMob and App
Invites.
And you'll notice that,
as I go, it might not
look like I'm doing much.
I'm just clicking a
bunch of + buttons
and clicking a
bunch of OK buttons,
but this tool is doing a lot of
work behind the scenes for me.
For Sign-In, it's creating
an OAuth client ID-- again,
with sensible defaults.
I can create a new
Google Analytics property
without having to jump to
the Google Analytics page.
And I can also link
up my AdMob account.
Normally, I would have to go to
two or three different screens
to get all this stuff working.
Now I can do it all
just from one site.
At the end, I also
get the nice lines
that I can copy and
paste into my pod file
so that I can install all the
libraries that I indicated
I was going to use.
You might also notice
right before this step,
I downloaded an info.plist file.
The way this works is this
new file in conjunction
with the Google
pod we have built
will simplify a few more
steps in the process for you.
So in the past,
usually when you were
done asking to add
Google Analytics
or add Google Sign-In,
we gave you constants
that you had to copy and
paste into your code,
like your analytics tracking
tag or your client ID.
And so on and so forth.
But now, our library can
simply read those constants out
of the plist file that
we give you to download.
So it saves a couple
of cutting and pasting
steps and some opportunity
for careless error.
So that'll be nice.
And of course, when you do
need to go in and adjust
your requests per second per
user quota limit for some API
or activate a certain type of
tracking in Google Analytics,
you can all those pages,
all those consoles.
They're all there for you,
but only when you need them.
Which is probably
not in the first two
minutes of creating a project.
If you want to see more, you
can check out our newly released
developers.google.com/ios page.
Yes, that's right.
We now have an
official landing page
in our documentation for iOS
developers, which is nice.
Isn't that nice?
Yes, it is.
It's great.
So now that I've
explained what we've
done to make things a little
more streamlined, let me- ah,
go away.
Good thing I had that with me.
I should have practiced
that bit in rehearsal.
Smells like linen.
I'm going to give you a tour of
what we have available for you.
I'm going to cover about 10 of
these services over the next 20
minutes, mostly focusing
on things that are new.
Hopefully not too much
of this is review.
But for those of you who
are joining us fresh online,
this should be new
for most of you.
So buckle up.
Here we go.
We're going to cover 10 services
over the next 20 minutes.
And we're going
to start with what
we have to make
it easier for you
to develop a more powerful app.
And we're going to
start with Google Maps.
Hey, look at that.
Moscone Center,
that's where we are.
How did it know?
Magic.
So you probably know about
the Google Maps SDK for iOS--
like, you can add some
super-fantastic, up-to-date,
accurate maps to your app, you
can add indoor maps in Street
View, which is always fun.
But most of this you
probably knew already.
What might be new to you
here is the Places API.
So Google has a massive database
of over 100 million stores
and restaurants and
bars and coffee shops
and theme parks and convention
centers all over the world.
It's a lot of places.
And you can use this
database to let the user
share where they are with
the meaningful location.
So instead of my telling
you, hey, why don't you
join me for a bite to
eat at 37.788204 latitude
and whatever longitude.
I could tell you, why don't
you join me for a bite to eat
at Ryoko's?
And here's the address and
here's a little embedded map,
which I think the engineer is
showing off here in the demo.
The Places API also includes
a few other nice utilities,
like a picker UI if you don't
feel like building your own,
where a user can
select their location
based on a list of locations
near where they are.
As well as an
auto-complete feature,
because typing proper names
on a phone is still no fun.
So we've had this on
Android for a little while.
You can do this
now on iOS as well.
This is a sneak preview
of a new app from Pixar,
where users can use the
Places API to choose
where a photo was taken.
So apparently we had Left Shark
visiting Google Headquarters.
He's a big deal
from what I hear.
Let's talk about Cast.
So you know about Chromecast,
the $35 device that
lets you put all of your
entertainment on your TV
while you use your phone as the
fanciest remote control ever.
So there's a whole lot of
Cast devices out there.
Did we not 17 million
at the keynote?
17 million sold?
It's a lot.
But I do want to clear up two
misconceptions about Cast.
First off, it's not just for
use with Android devices.
A large number of our users are
controlling their Cast device
with their iPhones as well.
And second, it's not just for
binge watching superhero shows.
It is great for that, I do it.
But Cast can also be great
for playing local multiplayer
games.
I mean, If you
think about it, you
have a TV that is perfect
for displaying a common game
state to everybody in the room.
And then every person
also has a phone
that's ideal for
displaying a little bit
of private information
and entering commands.
And if you think about
it, this is basically
the ideal set up for something
like a Texas Hold 'Em game.
But this also pretty much
describes every good board game
that's out there.
We think about it, like Scrabble
or Carcass Zone or Settlers
or House on Haunted Hill or
Dominion or any of those.
Most really good board games
rely on a public game state
that everybody can see
and then a little bit
of private information for
each player and a way for them
to enter commands.
This is something we really
couldn't do until a couple
years ago when everybody had
supercomputers in their pockets
with awesome displays
and a TV that they
could control with it.
And so to that end,
the Chromecast team
has announced the
Game Manager API.
And it's basically
here to help you
deal with all the tedious and
boring setup tasks you always
have to deal with
with multiplayer
games on any platform, frankly--
things like synchronizing
your game state across
devices and creating
a getting-started lobby and
dealing with people joining
and leaving and figuring
out who the host is
and a whole lot more.
I do encourage you
to check it out,
particularly if you
are a game developer
and you feel like you have
any kind of board game
or card game or co-op game that
would fit nicely in this model.
And it is cross-platform--
it works on Android and iOS,
because it turns out
we like to play games
with friends no matter what
kind of phone they have.
Also new for game developers
is the Cast Remote Display
for Games SDK.
And basically, to explain
how this one works,
I should probably
explain a little bit
around how Cast works, in
case you're not familiar.
Traditionally, the content
that's displayed on your TV
was powered by the
web browser that lives
on your little Cast device.
So hi there, fella.
So you might send commands
to it through your phone.
Say, play, pause,
play this movie.
But in general, if I'm,
say, streaming a movie off
of Netflix or Hulu, it's the
browser on the Chrome device
that's doing all the work.
It's going out
onto the internet,
it's getting this data
stream, it's downloading it,
it's displaying it on my TV.
So that means while
the movie's going on,
I can use my phone
for other things.
I don't have to
keep it on this app.
I can switch over and browse
IMDB or check my email.
Or even-- and you can
do this in a movie,
folks-- turn off
my device entirely.
So I don't have to worry
about my phone's attention
being elsewhere and
my movie stopping.
My Chromecast will
still plug away.
But there are a few times you
do want your phone to power
the display on your TV and
games are a really good example.
Like, imagine a
racing game where
you can use your phone with
its tilt sensor like a steering
wheel.
And your phone's fancy
Quad Core GPU chip
with a gazillion processors
is powering the game
on your giant TV screen.
And so, for these
kinds of cases,
we're introducing the remote
display for Games SDK for Cast.
And this will let your phone
write to your Cast device
as if it were another
display on the device.
So this is good for
single-player games as well as
multiplayer games.
But if you are building any kind
of game and you're thinking,
gosh, these graphics
sure look nice.
I bet they'd look really
good on a 50-inch TV screen.
You should definitely
look into this.
Again, available
on iOS and Android.
I'm going to talk
about Tag Manager next.
This is the only
library where we
don't have anything
new to announce here,
but I just really like it.
And I'm the speaker
and so I get to decide
these sorts of things.
How many people have used
Tag Manager, by the way?
For anything?
Yeah, a few of you.
Using it in an apps context--
the best way to think of it
is as a way to configure
your app via the cloud.
So imagine you've
got a game out there
and it suddenly starts
getting one-star reviews,
because people aren't
making it past level five.
And you're like oh, no, I
made level 5 way too hard.
Well, one option
would be to create
a new build with
some new settings
and get it uploaded
to the App Store
and approved and
sent out to everyone.
And hopefully they all
download the new version,
but if you had configured your
game using Google Tag Manager,
you could change the
difficulty settings
and send that right to the cloud
without any of that kerfuffle.
And the changes would
happen very quickly.
Tag Manager is also
rules-based, which
means that if people
with older phones
start complaining that your
game is running too slow,
you could tweak the number
of particles in your particle
system just for those people
who have older devices.
Or if you had managed all of
your apps text using Google Tag
Manager and then you
suddenly figure out
that your app is
big in Germany, you
could add an
entirely new language
on the fly doing
it all on the Cloud
without having to upload
a new version of your app.
So it's pretty neat.
Also kind of neat?
Tag Manager lets
you run experiments.
So you could make
your purchase button
say Purchase on half
the devices out there
and Buy Now on the other half
and see which converts better.
This is the kind of thing that
giant companies with server
engineers and business analysts
have been doing for a while,
but this is also now something
that a two-person shop can
try out as well thanks to
tools like Tag Manager.
So there's some really
fun stuff there.
I encourage you
to give it a look.
I'm going to talk
briefly about Cardboard,
but I guess we announced
iOS support at the keynote.
So most of you have
heard about this
and took the wind
out of my sails.
So, thanks guys.
But we realized you
can create a nice VR
device using the
powerful GPU and motion
sensors on your phone.
And you know what else
has a powerful GPU
and sophisticated
motion sensors?
Not just Android devices,
but iPhone ones as well.
And so there's
really no reason why
you couldn't run Cardboard
apps on an iPhone,
except that nobody had
written the SDK yet.
And so that's what our team did.
They have primarily been
focusing on the Unity plug-in
so that you can take your
Cardboard-enabled game
from Unity and port it to
iOS as well as to Android.
I've played with this
plug-in in the past.
This is a terrible
demo game that I made.
But it is a lot of fun.
I encourage you to
check it out and see
if there's snippets of your
game that might work well
as a 3D interactive experience.
It doesn't have to be your
entire game, by the way.
One nice thing about Cardboard
is you can take your phone,
put it in Cardboard, and
then put it out again.
So if you're making a base
management game and you think,
gee, it would be
nice if my user could
explore the base that they built
in a first-person VR setting.
You could just take
that part and put
that it into Cardboard
and not worry
about converting the entire
UI if you don't want to.
There are a lot of
design decisions
you should be aware of
when designing for VR.
And also when
designing for Cardboard
versus a more sophisticated,
sensory-replacement VR system.
Anyway, if you do
think this is something
you might be interested
in checking out,
we had a Make Believe session.
Make Believe is the
name of the title.
The session existed.
That was, I think,
earlier today.
And it has been recorded and
put online, so look for that.
And now to round out
the Develop section.
We're at, I think,
part five of 10.
Let's talk about Form.
Who knows about Form?
All right, a few of you.
So Form is unique in that
it is not a library that
makes your app better.
It is a tool to help
you build better apps.
Basically, it's a really cool
prototyping tool from a company
that Google acquired
back in November
and it's perfect for prototyping
animations and interactions.
So once you're
done sketching out
how your app is going to look,
you can take it into Form
and really start
to work on how it's
going to feel when your
user starts playing with it.
So all these animations
and interactions
are designed using these
elements called patches
in a flow chart like design.
And the nice thing
is, this doesn't
require any sort of Xcode
or programming or anything
like that.
So your designer can
spend their time tweaking
and tuning these animations
and adding features
as they go until everything
just feels right,
while your engineer can spend
their time browsing Hacker News
or fixing bugs, as time allows.
And the great thing
about all this
is feedback is
nearly instantaneous.
This format runs on your MacBook
and as you're making changes
to a view's opacity
or its position
or the dampening value of a
spring or anything like that,
those changes happen
right away on your device
that's connected to it.
I mean, you don't even have
to stop and restart the app.
You just get to see
everything happen
right away, in real time.
And I find that super-tight
feedback loop is really useful
when you're trying
to zero in on making
something feel just right.
It's really fun and useful.
So the team is going to be
launching version 1.3 very
soon.
I believe it's going through
the approval process now.
But I can give you a sneak
preview of some of the features
that they're going to be
announcing in version 1.3.
First up are some new widgets
or patches for you to play with,
as well as an SDK for you
to write your own custom
patches, which is cool.
There are going to be
easier ways for you to share
your prototypes with others.
There are going to be some
new motion curves, new ways
to get your view from
point A to point B, as well
as a few different
built-in animation timings.
So different variations of
slow-in, fast-out, fast-in,
slow-out, and so
on and so forth,
as well as support for
more material design.
Things like the card element
or the ripple effect that
happens when you touch a view.
And by the way, this
is another thing
not just for Android devices.
Try adding a little bit of
material design to your app.
We have and I think
it looks pretty good.
So Form used to cost $80, but
since the acquisition is now
free, which is a
savings of-- anybody?
Shout it out.
Yeah, $80, right.
You win 20 internet points.
So yeah, that's Form.
So building a
compelling app is great.
But let's look at
what you can do
to keep your users coming back.
Let's talk a little
about Engagement.
And first up, new for
iOS is app indexing.
So the idea behind app indexing
is, there's a lot of you
out there who have
apps and also have
websites that closely mirror
the content of those apps.
Let's say, for instance, you
are a restaurant review site.
And I'm searching for
donuts in the Mission
and your site shows up.
So that's great.
But what happens when
I click on that link
from inside the
Google search app?
Well, it takes users
to your website
where you're probably
showing me one
of those annoying interstitials.
So you go and
check out your app.
Which, I mean, I get it.
You've built this nice app,
you want to take users to it.
But I just want my donut info.
And you're getting
in the way of me
and my doughnuts and that
makes me hungry and angry.
It makes me hangry and
you wouldn't like me
when I'm hangry.
So to address this issue, we
take advantage of deep links.
And if you don't know
what deep links are,
they're basically like URLs.
But unlike a typical one
that, say, points to a website
out there, these are URLs
that point to your app.
And you can include all
sorts of data within this URL
so that your app can
interpret it to, for instance,
point to specific
content within your app.
So the way this works, the
way you take advantage of this
is-- for every
page on your site,
you would generate
some metadata that
includes a deep link that
points to that page's content
in your iOS and Android apps.
Then the next time
Google crawls your site,
it makes a note
of these mappings.
It says, a-ha, this is where
I can find the same content
in your various apps.
And then the next time I
search for donuts, Google
will once again
bring up your site.
But because it knows
that this content now
exists within your
app, it will instead
display a deep link that points
directly to your app right
within the search results.
And incidentally,
we only show this
to users who have
your app installed.
So we can still show
your regular web content
to users who don't and show your
apps content to users who do.
Either way, your users now
can get to your content
with one click, which is great.
App indexing is something
that we started rolling out
last week to a small
number of people
with a small number
of initial partners.
I believe OpenTable, Zillo,
and Pinterest are among them.
And we are hoping
to expand this as we
get further feedback
from our partners
and our users and
everyone is happy.
So definitely go check
out the documentation.
There's a place
for you to sign up
to get invited into
the app invites list.
So if this sounds like
something that would fit you,
definitely check it out.
Also new for iOS is app invites.
And this is also
in beta right now.
But this tool
basically gives you
what you need to create a nice
word-of-mouth experience so
that users can share your
app with their friends.
Because as we all
know, word-of-mouth
is a fantastic way for people
to find out about your app.
It tends to drive more
conversions than anything else
out there.
I think we all
know this, but I'm
going to tell you a story
anyway of my friend Kelly.
This is her, head
not drawn to scale.
But every Christmas,
my friend Kelly,
whose sister works for the Gap,
sends me a friends and family
coupon code for like
a 20%-off discount.
And I love this thing.
Every year, I look
forward to it-- like,
when's Kelly's email?
When's it going to get here?
Why hasn't she
sent it to me yet?
Am I still her friend?
Oh no, what's happened.
Oh yay, it's here.
And then I go off and I
buy five dozen shirts.
Which is crazy, because if Gap
send me an email for a 20%-off
sale, I wouldn't even open it.
I'd be like, whatever,
marketing, blah, blah, blah.
And I'd archive it.
But because this is
from a friend of mine,
this becomes a special event
that I am looking forward to.
And that's the power
of friend referrals
and the kind of thing that
can drive users to your app.
So app invites gives
you a way to harness
this same kind of energy.
Let's say I'm done
ordering food online
through this food ordering
app-- a lot of my examples
are about food, aren't they?
I should not write
this during lunch.
Anyway, I have an opportunity
to send a free meal to a friend.
So app invites
would bring up a UI
where the user can choose to
send these app invitations
to any of their friends.
You can send these messages
via SMS or through email.
We also include
some recommendations
based on who people who we
think are hungry, I guess.
And these invitations
come with a URL
that expands to include
a deep link-- there
we are with deep links again--
that takes players to your app
or prompts them to install
it from the App Store.
Because it's a
deep link, you can
include whatever
information you want to
with it, like a discount code.
So when the user is
done installing your app
and they open it
up, your app can
read in that code that
brought users to your app
in the first place and
say, oh, hey, look.
Here's that free meal that
your friend Todd sent you.
Your user is happy because
they have a free meal
and you're happy because
you have a new customer.
And everybody wins.
And this does work
cross-platform.
So if you were to open that
same link on an Android device,
we would take users to the
Play Store version of your app
instead, because
we're smart like that.
So up next, this is
probably the feature
I am most excited about.
This is Google Cloud
Massaging and this
is our revolutionary
new-- wait, I'm sorry.
What?
Oh.
I've actually been informed
this is Google Cloud Messaging.
Still cool.
Kind of wanted the
backrub, but still cool.
The way Google Cloud
Messaging works
is, this is our
service that helps
you send server-generated
notifications to your users.
So your server
would send a message
to the Google Cloud
Messaging-- or GCM
as the kids say-- server.
And we would really
those notifications
to your target's Android
device or your Chrome browser.
But now if you upload your
APNS certificate to us,
we can send notifications to
their iOS devices as well.
Which means you could
send a notification
to any of these
devices or browsers
with just one call
instead of three somewhat
different code paths
that all basically
end up doing the same thing.
So hopefully, this should make
your life a whole lot easier.
Also new with Google
Cloud Messaging
is the idea of topics.
Basically, the way
this works is your app
can subscribe to any number of
topics on behalf of your user.
I think we allow up to
1,000,000 subscriptions per app.
So let's say, for instance,
you have a sports app
and I want to be
notified anytime
the Red Sox are playing.
Well, in the past,
to do this you'd
probably have to
record my preference
in a database somewhere and do
this big select-users-where,
blah, blah, blah query and
then loop through the results
and then send notifications
to each of those users
and then the results,
keeping track of what device
I had so that you could
call the appropriate call.
Well, with Google
Cloud Messaging,
basically my device would
just ask the GCM server, hey,
please subscribe me to
the Boston baseball topic.
Then you can simply say,
let's send a notification
to everybody who has
subscribed to this topic.
And I, along with all the
other Red Sox fans out
there, would get
notified with one call.
You don't need that database to
keep track of it all anymore.
You can throw it
out unless you're
using it for other things.
But you don't need to use it
for this anymore, which is nice.
Google Cloud Messaging also
supports upstream messages,
which is a lightweight
way for your client
to communicate to your server.
And if you're like me and
you're like, well, why would
you do this instead of just
communicating with your server
directly?
How does this help you?
The answer is
basically this allows
you to support some lightweight
communication from your users
without your having to
stand up a full-on server
on the internet.
I mean, your server in this
case could basically just
be your laptop running a
little daemon in the background
that checks GCM
every once in awhile.
So if you want to get a
little bit of information
from your users but
think, gosh, a server
seems like an
awful lot of work--
look into Google Cloud
Messaging for that.
So I think we're down to
the last two, but the most
important two because
they're the ones that
help you earn money.
So yes, because there's a point
in every startup founder's life
when they would like to
stop eating instant ramen
and start eating
fancy hipster ramen,
I guess-- which is delicious.
And I'm on food again,
I've got to stop that.
So we're going to start
with Google Analytics.
And honestly, this could
have gone in any of the three
categories I discussed earlier,
because analytics has basically
become the lifeblood
of a lot of apps.
And there's a lot you can
measure with Google Analytics,
things like how many
new users I have,
my active users, where
they're coming from,
what devices they have.
You can get real-time
analytics, find out
how many people are
using your app right now
and what screens they're on.
We allow screen
flow, so you can see
what screens or view
controllers your users
are spending their
time on and how
they get from one to the next.
It's also possible to
get some really good
demographic information, like
the age range or the gender
or the general interests of
the people using your app.
So you can find out, is
it guys in their 20's that
are using my app or is
it women in their 50's,
because depending
on the answer, you
might want to market it
a little differently.
You can also measure
funnels towards goals.
Here, the developer is seeing
how many people are making it
to the app rating screen.
And if this were a
multi-step process,
you could also figure out
where they were dropping out.
You can track crashes
and exceptions too,
across different
versions of your app.
And track all sorts of custom
events that you wanted to find.
Here, the developer's keeping
track of how often people
level up in his or her game.
But one more recent
feature that we
added that we're
very excited about
is App Install Attribution.
So basically,
Google has partnered
with over 20 different
ad networks out there
so you can break out a
lot of your user data
by the ad network that brought
those users to your app
in the first place.
So what this means is, instead
of going to 20 different ad
network sites and logging in and
looking at clickthrough rates
and trying to make something
meaningful out of it,
you can go to Google
Analytics and in one view,
see important things, like
which ad networks are giving you
customers who retain best.
Or even better,
which ad networks
are giving you the customers
with the highest lifetime
value.
Probably something that
we'd all be interested in.
And last but not
least, we've got AdMob.
I think probably most of
us know what AdMob is,
but it's the service
that lets you monetize
your app by displaying
banner ads and interstitial
ads within it.
This has been available on
iOS for a few years now,
but there are a few new features
that the team would like
to make sure I tell you about.
First up is native ads.
So this is in limited beta and
we are gradually rolling it out
to more folks as we go.
And if you're not familiar with
this concept, basically the way
this works is, instead of
your just allocating space
within your view and we
slap a banner on top of it,
you would work with
AdMob to specify
how you would like to style the
ads so that it better fits in
with your app's look and feel.
We can give you an ad
that fits your style
without making some brand
manager somewhere freak out.
So they get an ad
they still like,
you get an ad that fits
in a little better,
and everybody's happy.
This is really good for ads that
have more of a distinct look
and feel.
You can get your ads to feel
like they're a little more part
of the experience.
I believe Atari recently added
this to their Roller Coaster
Tycoon game.
It's still clearly an ad.
We don't want to kind
of trick anybody.
But at the same time, this
is a little more built
into the experience than if we
just had an ad banner pop up
from the bottom of the screen.
The other new feature that
I think is really cool
is Audience Builder.
And this is what
happens when you
add the power of
Google Analytics
to your ads powered by AdMob.
It's a really great way
of getting the right ads
to the right people.
For example, I think
it's well known
that in a freemium game
with microtransactions,
a large number of your
audience is never going
to buy anything, which is sad.
And you're thinking,
gosh, I'd sure
like to monetize all
these other people.
But you're worried
that if you bring up
something like an
interstitial ad with video,
that might add just friction
that it might turn off
a buyer or two.
And you don't want to do that.
Well, with Audience
Builder, you could say, hey,
let's only show these video
interstitial ads to the people
who haven't bought anything.
And for those people that
have bought stuff, well, maybe
you could show them a banner
ad for an in-game item--
or show them nothing at all.
It's up to you, use the strategy
that you feel would work best.
But we could get even
crazier than this.
We could say, hey, maybe I want
to show an ad for a power-up.
But it doesn't make sense
to show this to everybody.
You only want to
show it, let's say,
to the people who have
made it past the first five
tutorial levels.
And maybe you also
want to show it
to people who have had to
restart a level more than three
times.
These people, they're
getting frustrated.
They would probably really
appreciate this power
that you're selling.
So now you suddenly
have an ad that's
much more relevant
to these people.
And we're getting the right
ad to the right people.
Or let's say, I've
got some players
that are really competitive
in the player-vs-player stuff.
Well, I'm going to show them
ads for more in-game weapons.
But for my players
who are really
into spending their time
dressing up their avatar,
I can show them house ads
for more awesome hats.
It's all about
getting the right ads
to the people who
really appreciate it.
And there's a lot more,
more than I could probably
cover in this talk.
But this is some of the
crazy, awesome power
you get when you combine
Google Analytics with AdMob.
So we did it.
Yes, runner, that was
a lot of libraries.
So I want to circle back to
the whole reason I'm here.
Once I explain that, yes,
Google does do a lot on iOS,
often the next question
I get is, well, why?
Why would Google
spend any time at all
on providing services that
make apps better for iOS?
And the answer is
that-- again, this
isn't really about
Android versus iOS,
as much as the press
would like you to believe.
This whole conference is
really about all of you,
the developers.
And so, yes, there has a
lot of Android M and Wear
and whatever announcements.
But at the end of the day, I/O
is our developer conference.
And It's about
celebrating the people
in this room and everybody
online-- hi, online folks-- who
are using Google services
to power their apps.
And we want to make
this experience great.
And that starts
with building out
the cross platform part of it.
Nobody is really that
excited about implementing
two entirely different sets
of services to make their app
do the exact same thing on
two different platforms.
I'm not.
And if we can do that
while also making
the process a little more
streamlined-- no, you go back.
If we can do that while making
the process more streamlined,
we can not only give your
app a really great head
start in the world, but we can
make building it even somewhat
delightful.
That said, we're
not quite there yet.
We do recognize we're
really just getting started.
And there's a lot more
I think we could do
and I'm hoping that
I will have more
to share with you over
the next few months.
Otherwise, I'm out of a job.
But in the meantime,
I encourage you
to check out our documentation.
Give our new configuration flow
a try-- it is awfully neat.
Also, shameless plug-- I have
a show in our Google Developers
channel called Route 85.
Hey, look-- apparently
I only own one shirt.
You should check it out.
Google needs to pay me more
so I can buy a second shirt.
It is chock-full of iOS info,
including a really fun video
that we just released a half
an hour ago that talks all
about CocoaPods in more detail.
And if you can figure out
where the title came from,
you win 30 more internet points.
So thank you so much for coming.
And now if you'll
excuse me, I really
need to get back to
eating some snacks.
We do have some
time for questions,
but I'll be honest--
I'm still learning
a lot of this stuff myself.
So my answer will
probably be, I don't know
or it's my first day.
All right, you can
just talk to me after.